lilly Reinhardt pens a sappy love poem
for Cole Sprouse his birthday it's
really sweet the two may be battling
breakup rumors but Lily has a lot of
love for Cole she took to Instagram to
write this heartfelt poem I tried to
find a poem that I could send you
because my words were failing me but I
searched and found nothing that did you
justice all of these love poems can't
get it right
no one else's words could ever fit they
haven't known the fortune it is to love
you
sappy nighttime birthday poem for Cole
Sprouse meanwhile on her instace Tori
Lilly posted a photo of Cole's twin
brother Dylan writing happy birthday
baby this comes just over a week after
Lilly appeared to shut down rumors that
the couple had broken up after two years
of dating she posted their joint W
Magazine cover with the caption breaking
a reliable source has confirmed that
none of you know Cole echoed something
similar writing unprecedented Cole
Sprouse and Lilly Reinhart consume the
flesh of reliable sources to fuel their
bacchanalian sex cult I think on strong
he caught up with the Riverdale co-stars
at Comic Con
just days before breakup reports hit
we're gonna get through it
[Music]
the two gave us some insight on Betty
and jugheads relationship ahead of the
new season Chuck ed goes to prep school
the season so he's only back in
Riverdale in the weekend that distance
yeah and I think that's going to
inevitably put stress on the
relationship between Betty and Jughead I
think it might be a little bit tense
they might fall turn away from each
other only to come back together at way
stronger and yeah I think they're gonna
I think they're gonna be really good
[Music]